willkommen zu einer neuen folge jump
lieben nach langer langer zeit jumpy
pause heute eine neue folge und mit
dabei ist der il volo der wand der
wohnung wird uns heute bisher dabei
begleiten wie wir ein bisschen john
player gespielt ich komme gerade direkt
aus der klausur leute und bin dem er
erfolgreich zerstört matsche in der
birne
aber so mancher stelle ich das vor wenn
ihr okay es muss mir eine gute mit
verein verlassen stellt euch vor
stellt euch vor ihr nehmt euer gehirn
hat dann fünf mal mit einem leopard
panzer drüber sagt die überbleibsel auf
sorry wenn es jetzt sehr sehr drastisch
wird in der schilderung packt das essen
weg am besten also fleißig getestet
aufzuessen zentrifugiert das dann haut
das 50 mal durch ein sieb und dann bin
ich dann wisst ihr wie ich mich gerade
fühle so ist kann man group und deswegen
ich habe leider keinen job mehr gespielt
gott bin ich schlecht oder hallo ich
schäme mich grad viel mehr
ich hab den ersten paar wochen nicht ist
ja auch nicht der partner aber du wirst
schon lange nicht mehr gespielt ja
entschuldigung nicht mit kanalwasser das
ist leider hat den partys auch als
einmal gehabt ich glaube im livestream
aber den förster geschafft keine ahnung
was los ist das ist aber was aber ich
sage also jetzt unabhängig davon wie wir
jetzt gerade zurecht sind der part ist
für den ersten part relativ knapp ja das
war aber natürlich alles ganz okay ich
hab jetzt dummerweise da diese blöde
trap door noch herunter geklappt das
heißt ich kann da jetzt nicht so direkt
drauf springen aber so wird das ich
richtig viele kekse die apollon kekse ja
vier stück schon okay wir wollten noch
die räder machen kleine tee party
lasst die finger davon leute böse das
keine gute sache
mögen sie nicht gut ich muss die
vorbildfunktion erfüllt werden genau
genau drogen sind nicht gut niemals
kekse der fall da okay okay ich habe
jetzt auch den anfang mal geschafft
alles klar
ich hab nur gerade ein ganz ganz großes
problem und das problem ist dass meine
maus bisschen rum speisten mit jetzt
gleich denn ich kann nur weniger mit
mauspad spielen das geht nicht also wenn
meine maus auf dem mauspad ist dann dann
dreht sie durch die kommt gar nicht mehr
klar
ich weiß nicht warum aber ich glaube
weil das mauspad uneben ist also deshalb
schon so ein kreisrundes mit plastik
oberfläche das kannst kannst du
wahrscheinlich na ja ja ja und das ist
halt irgendwie immer geknickt wollen und
jetzt kannst du die maus darauf nicht
mehr bedienen deswegen spielt auf einem
tisch und meine hand ist irgendwie so
ein bisschen keine ahnung wo man sagen
wie ich das jetzt sagen ohne dass
behinderte
na ja ich bin auch irgendwie so
gestresst deswegen habe ich noch so
schwitzige hände von der klausur jetzt
auf dem tisch mit maus irgendwie optimal
will keiner wissen aber alles klar
so wie sieht es bei dir aus twist
edmonton ne-yo läuft eigentlich nicht
anspringen geschafft zu fahren bei mir
sind noch ein typ der zieht voll davon
aber mit startschwierigkeiten ich diese
automatismen die man so die früher so
drin hatte die muss jetzt wieder wieder
bekommen so diese wolken serie der die
ich früher im schlaf machen können
mittlerweile muss ich mir überlegen was
kommt jetzt da raus kommt da ich hab
jetzt schon lange nicht mehr gespielt
naja ich hab ne weile pause gemacht
heute ich könnte euch nicht sagen wie
lange aber ich war wahrscheinlich aber
ich will nicht alles verlernt haben komm
lass mich bitte bisschen vorankommt doch
wie schlecht ich auch da stehe okay okay
alles gut so übrigens leute
jetzt hat ihm die klausur vorbei ist
habe ich auch wieder zeit für live cams
alles klar
wahrscheinlich werde ich werde in den
nächsten tagen dann mal einen livestream
plan ausarbeiten so dass er nicht immer
darauf warten müssen dass ich dann mal
auf twitter sage ja heute live stream
heute keinen live stream
weil wenn ich dann so unter dem song war
so unter druck bin dass leute irgendwie
darauf warten dass ich jeden tag strömen
dann ist es auch ein bisschen das
bisschen ja es tut mir leid und die
leute ja ich meine du kannst du kannst
dich gar nicht so viel aber wenn ich das
auch schon sehe wenn ich immer so am
wochenende ein paar tagen an das
streamen oder sowas und unter den ferien
und an die woche drauf hoffen die leute
teilweise am abend egal an welchem tag
immer darauf warten sich stream dabei
habe ich mir videos streamen das kommt
mir zu schade vor
naja stimmt macht es nicht leute
deswegen das ist halt auch ok ok
computer egal aber der abstand ist nicht
so groß heute ich hab einfach noch gar
nichts ich habe ich noch zwei parts vor
mir ich habe immer noch fast jeder ist
ein goldtor echt okay ich bin schon voll
gold beziehungsweise chain okay die
ersten lifte schon so also in equipment
mäßig gehe jetzt aber ja deswegen ich
mache einfach mal einen festen stream
timetable sozusagen so ein stundenplan
für mich wenn ich es prima wenn ich in
die schule gehen muss und dann wisst ihr
einfach immer beispielsweise jetzt also
der steht noch nicht fest aber beweise
immer montag dienstag donnerstag oder
montag mittwoch donnerstag steht immer
sebastian oder kann ich auftritt schauen
und dann ist ja immer um 8 uhr ein so da
kann ich nämlich auch bewusst abschalten
dann wenn ich am samstag ganz prima
nicht sondern sagen okay heute pause
alle wissen dass pause ist und keiner
ist enttäuscht von heute an kleinsten
kommt es war also ab gemacht deswegen
ist das eine super sache
so sieht es bei dir aus mittlerweile hat
gewonnen aber wissen was du bist ein
ziel und das nur ein goldtor
ich habe jetzt eine gold hose weißem
helm der schule leder jazz plate aber
dafür habe ich ein eisen schwarz alter
übertreiben ich habe mir schon ewig
nicht verkraften können und bestehe mich
in jeder aufnahme darüber dann nehme ich
einfach nicht auf
ja ja ja ja ich kenne das so gut das
problem du bist auf playmate immer so
kurz davor irgendwas greifen zu können
oder kurz davor irgendwas entscheiden zu
können sollte noch irgendwie so ein
fitzelchen vom erfahrungs banken fehlt
das ist halt wie stressig das gab es mal
zeit rot gold abzustauben gemetzel
herzens einer kerze
dioki jetzt dirigent origin alles gut
alles gut oder konnte nicht genau
erinnern lassen lasters lasters lassen
einfach nicht okay die boxen sich
gegenseitig die runde
du hast dir ohne ultraschnell durch
gewalt geht also das war direkt an tief
hinter mir
hier nämlich so geartet kann ich jetzt
auch im ziel warten oder sowas aber dann
ist es ein direkter typ bei mir gewesen
dass es war richtig schnell ich gucke
auf die aufnahmezeit wir sind schon im
deathmatch schon der minuten des matches
und jetzt gerade bei 27 das ultra
geländes das ist richtig kraft schnell
ich leben und erleben gibt es nicht weil
ich mache combo längst rechts oben unten
muss ich was dran ändern da ist ist das
ist der moment wo ich den spiegel sparen
sollte
kannst du kannst ihn spielt schon nach
der aktion da 30 zu 9 spiele nie mehr
sehen
erst mal zur therapeutin und abgestaubt
ich schäme mich kann ich wirklich so
schlecht können wir uns gehör
ok alles klar
und hier wurde eine 1000 keppert hier
villiger will wirklich die ganze zeit
macht macht aber mein bester kampf die
klärung kommt nichts raus bist du dran
bin ich ja die kiste dran da ist
zitierten deger das einfach den stick
und zwei eisenbahn sind renten futures
flughafen finden
die hab jetzt natürlich gehören
irgendwas natürlich bekommt das richtig
ist ich hab das eisen schwer genug
vorteil ist die frage ich musste mein
handy in den griff bekommen so doch sein
leben und das 0 2
das wahrscheinlich die kürzeste jumpy
grunde meines lebens
alter schwede ist von gott oh gott ich
idiot ich habe die anrede wand okay okay
okay gut das war so dumm von mir als ich
bin
das war so gut alte das war auch nicht
erwartet dass das klappt ich dachte
wieder zurück gegangen bist dass du mich
irgendwie sehen während beispiel das aus
dem blickwinkel überhaupt nichts alter
das war das war ich ja ich hab bis jetzt
ist da hinten
ich wäre verfolgt von edmonton erwischt
okay jetzt eins gegen eins eins gegen
eins am rand bruder einst king 11 punkte
das du eigentlich sicher voll arena
nicht ganz ins sechseinhalb ich habe
aber 50 trotz der schon ja die gäste
ja das ist der verein hat jetzt ist die
frage ob du mich findest public in die
mitte wo ich hatte ein herz mit dem
energy guter kambodscha ich habe schon
gemerkt dann kam so ich weiß nicht
kennst du das auch in dem kampf wenn ihr
so schräg steht und du weißt wer jetzt
den hit gebt er hat den kampf eigentlich
schon gewonnen
ja ja ich war gut wenigsten verdient
eine beschreibung man sich gefallen hat
das gerne daumen nach oben da wir sehen
uns bald wieder mit neuen formaten timo
jakits wird wiederkommen und rote top
ten wird wiederkommen und macht's gut
und